welcome to this video playing zip aquino
zip aquino probably not the right
pronunciation okay the quadruple
fianchetto yeah that's a very very solid
way to play at the Black Watch has sung
for a long time struggle to find an
advantage in this type of position and I
just want to make sure not that blonde
or something on the diagonal can easily
happen with a night moving away and then
your sunday losing your bishop here but
you cannot do it really and only ninety
eight or nine h5 and then I have fd2 I
don't mind that yeah the only issue for
black and this position is that I will
get a night to d5 and term well you
cannot really go e6 to make it go away
and you have to live with this piece
this is not this is not easy to do you
can do exactly that try to initiate this
counter play with be five but that's it
basically if not not much else h4 h5 can
be an idea I want to weaken his
structure a bit maybe provoke him to
play h drive himself one question is
what to do with the rooks so now I'm
getting this with tempo
yeah well maybe in first double rooks on
the default it's it's not like I'm
pressurizing something here on the D far
but I'm ready to maybe switch it over
the rook on the fourth-ranked and maybe
maybe I can really use this h5 idea okay
well 95 is not not really good I wonder
maybe night ever maybe am now rook f4 is
an idea with the sacrifice a sacrifice
on f6 that seems that it irritated him a
bit mm it's their night 95 maybe I can
go here 95 root t five actually
yeah that's an interesting way to play
now h5 is an idea and Knight f6 I just
take and play Knight g4 with a fantastic
compensation probably getting getting
the exchange back right away ok and now
i have h5 really one night g 494 is
interesting the threatens night h6 made
basically if i go here yet this is
actually nice what what is this move
here 'if I've night h6 is also leading
to disaster f6 maybe and f6 is not
really attractive yeah but what's
necessary I guess okay maybe just back
now just back now to be able to
recapture with the night ok here's the
counter play age 5 maybe maybe why
should take maybe I should just take him
yeah I get the get the night over to see
50 is not taking with the night
surprisingly can you take your first and
then maybe h5 on 95 95 you will take ok
i plug away i go here
maybe g five year actually should I play
this intermediate capture Mutschler I
don't really know the it's tricky tricky
position yeah I have this play on the
King side but b3 is also week so it's
not not entirely clear how to how to
assess the whole thing if i go to see to
maybe just quincy to attacking g6 yeah
rook g4 also coming
maybe you can really just in play here
play this to have 95 group G 495 I can
give this check but it's not it's not
leading to a direct k or anything I
wonder and about be4 takes 97 and Luke
c7 I mean maybe
hmm
what to tell them is this really tricky
to play you seven hangs 195 I wanted to
go out for
tough not really sure about all this
KF seven local currency for LC ok now f4
instill you something to hang so maybe
ok Quincy 496 is not a good idea time
morning I can go back to see four but
then you'll take him this is coming no
idea really no idea queen bee three I
have I can take you seven I think this
should be ok with the night with a
threat with 96 g3 hangs but it still
should be ok the the general position
taking on g6 now we need to close the
window they cover this for the moment
to get Queens traded night takes there
is no p8 so probably just just little
drawback here very slightly better
coordinated check so maybe maybe this
slight edge no I can take a look check
check check mate yeah tough game tough
game really I don't know it it always
seemed to me that I have a little
something but he defended this well
Murray very clearly I don't know around
here but sits it's probably equal I mean
probably is just equal I was trying some
things but f-for was risk him maybe not
good 2096 SS coming rook age 80 rook h8s
giving us very strong by the calm and
this type of move less difficult to see
this kind of slow move where f5 now is a
threat yeah
I'm very bad shape him didn't see the
move at all f5 is huge stride ok aunty
it's probably still about equal all
night h6 was strong yeah we didn't have
much time on the clock between a seven
is good for black but he decided to to
simplify matters the idea it's it's it's
just so equal but somehow he he lost the
threat here bit and Trust give up a pawn
and then check then then blundered
blundered the rook so bit lucky okay
thanks for watching